welcome to architecting with google
cloud machine learning continues to be
applied to use cases across industries
the airlines and transportation industry
is no exception
i'm thrilled today to chat with xenia
cristina a machine learning platform
manager at flyer labs where her team
leverages data and machine learning to
help airlines better forecast demand set
prices and optimize revenue i'm
particularly excited to also have xenia
give us a peek into the core components
of flyer labs's ml platform welcome
senior and thanks for joining today can
you start off by telling us a bit about
yourself
sure hello
uh yes my name is xenia and i
have been with flyer for three years so
in general i have about eight years of
experience in the industry in multiple
domains and i
but however i started machine learning
and
i started working in machine learning
only three years ago and now can you
tell us a little about your company
flyer labs flyer labs
is a companies in bringing intelligence
to airlines so we are trying to use
machine learning and ai to be able to
predict demand and optimize the pricing
for the airlines so we want to make sure
that every flight at a takeoff is 100
full in bringing the maximum revenue to
the airline oh wow that's great and you
know that that feels especially
particularly relevant and important
today for the airlines industry in the
midst of the pandemic and you know how
consumer behaviors changes really really
fast um so now we are here to talk a
little about machine learning could you
discuss some of the top use cases mlml
is applied to we basically have only one
only one use case for now so we are
taking all the historical data from the
airline we are taking the competitors
content competitors information we are
taking information about future events
at the origin of the dis or the
destination of the flight and putting
this all into our models and outputting
the demand forecasts which are used to
optimize the pricing and deliver this to
the airline that are lately lately used
in their production systems and and
before we dive into that use case and
and how you've architected a platform
around it i think i wanted to dig a
little bit deeper into your team and how
it fits within the
broader flyer labs organization i think
a lot of companies today they might only
have one data science team they struggle
to operationalize ml models um could you
talk a little bit about your team and
the other teams that flyer that are
tackling this problem yeah so flyer is
mostly built around data science so of
course we have more than one data
science team
we have a data science organization
which my team is a part of so this data
science organization consists of three
teams that the science team itself
machine learning platform and machine
learning infrastructure team
besides this organization there is also
validation team which is all which is
kind of participate in uh
machine learning data science as well
but they're they're a little bit apart
but i will talk i will talk about them
as well um so
data science team is a team
responsible for basically building a
model itself
uh they are pure that the scientists not
uh trying not to touch any mlml ops then
machine learning platform is the team
that builds
the platform as
you can understand from the name builds
a platform around this models and
machine learning so this is the platform
that is used to run inference and
production environment and not only
production environment on daily basis
and deliver i basically use the models
on the production system and then there
is a machine learning infrastructure
team which is focusing on
empowering data science team and machine
learning platform team to do their job
uh so they are mostly focusing on tools
around all of this so
that's how it looks and then validation
team is a team that um
that is responsible for uh
testing the models let's say they're
trying to see how the models are
performing in real life are over over uh
many days of uh
over many days of being used in the
production so they are trying to val
validate how good our models basically
are great yeah thanks for sharing it i i
think it's it's great to see that you're
really at a maturity level where you
have different teams focused on
different parts of the life cycle um and
and really optimizing optimizing the the
time to get models into production and
you really have great delegation of
duties across teams here um so we are
here again to talk about architecting on
google cloud so maybe you could give us
a little bit of the story around why you
initially chose google cloud a number of
years ago
we made this decision around six years
ago when we were still a small startup
uh and one of the
one of the main reasons probably was a
google
bootcamp google startup powering program
where google gave us a credit and we
were able to use uh used google cloud
platform basically for free for a while
uh this was a
this was quite quite a big uh thing for
us because we didn't have much uh much
money at the time let's say
uh and but that was not the only reason
uh the other reason was that um google
had a great support for kubernetes
probably the best at the time on the
market and we we really wanted to uh to
be able to use kubernetes in our
solution so uh this is reason number two
uh why are we staying with google what
do we like about this is still the great
great kubernetes support and uh bigquery
which uh bigquery is
basically we our whole company runs on
bigquery so uh we are tightly bound to
this and uh
so far it's been been working great for
us yeah thanks yeah great great to hear
that story i'm glad you know uh flyer
labs is still on gcp kind of growing
with your business um and it you know if
it feels like really that big bet on
bigquery and kubernetes you know has
paid off and is really uh part of your
your core product offering um so uh now
let's get into the ml platform itself uh
uh in addition to bigquery and
kubernetes what are some of the other
gcp services that make up your ml
platform today
uh sure we're using dataflow we're using
vertex ci we're using kubeflow and
tensorflow
okay great so you you seem to have
really adopted some of the industry
standards and really focused on open
source which i think is a big core
component of google cloud as well we are
you know one of our main objectives is
really to support uh support the
community especially in the open source
space um so now can you maybe talk about
the main components of your ml
architecture at a higher level to start
sure uh three main components are our
three
pipelines uh training data generation
pipeline model training pipeline and
daily inference pipeline
great thanks yeah i think breaking it
down like that um really uh really makes
things a little bit clearer i think
sometimes architecting a broad ml system
can feel intimidating or complex for
teams but focusing on how data flows
through the system with your three
pipeline design uh really makes it uh
much more understandable so can you
start off with the training data set
generation pipeline of course uh
training data set generation demands the
most resources
uh so how it works it
uses keep flow as an orchestrator it
pulls data from bigquery it's usually
a few years of airline historical data
and then it runs on data flow using beam
programming model as an output it
generates tf records that we later put
in a google cloud storage and register
in our model metadata store module
metadata store so this pipeline
is very demanding that's why we run it
on a google tpu and even though tpu is
very
very fast it still takes hours to
generate such a trading data data set
yeah i think i think it's you know
somewhat common knowledge that data
preparation is still
the biggest task within within a machine
learning platform within a machine
learning pipeline and it's you know it's
it's interesting to kind of hear your
story uh resonate with that that is it
is the most demanding and resource
intensive part of the entire pipeline um
so now once you have the raw data
processed into tf records what happens
then can you walk us through the
training pipeline yeah then there is
another platform there is another
pipeline that also uses keep flow as an
orchestrator and then it takes tf
records from this generated by previous
pipeline it takes tf records from google
cloud storage and it takes a model
model source code which is just a python
package
so it runs in vertex ai
and as the output it generates trained
model uh in the format of say tensorflow
saved model we put it in gcp as well in
google cloud storage as well and
register in model metadata storage so
modern metadata storage i already
mentioned it let me tell
let me tell you about this this is our
internal tool that we use for
uh
as you can guess from the name storing
model metadata so it has
it has models
with
it has models with parameters and the
parameters usually include model
type
model let's say purpose model id
uh for which client this model is being
registered and for which in which
environment we want to use this model so
it can be a production model integration
model staging development model and so
on and then in this modern metadata
storage we also keep a history of our
data set so it also has
versions of data set and their ids
so later you can just reuse by
looking reuse models and reuse data sets
by just looking at the model method
storage and thanks for sharing that i
think model registries and
model metadata storage is is really an
interesting topic today i think you know
when you start with your first model or
your first five models just storing
those models in a blob storage is
sufficient but really when you scale to
tens hundreds of models really
developing a specific workflow around
managing models becomes very important
in the ml lifecycle
so now now that you have models of
course the next important step is
deploying those models to run
predictions can you now walk us through
the final pipeline around serving uh yes
so this is our pipeline that we call
daily inference and this is basically
this is actually the pipeline that my
team is focusing on so um this pipeline
is
listening to clients data so
it's listening to pub subs from bigquery
where the client's data is being dropped
after we collect all the necessary data
the pipeline is triggered
and as an orchestration we use here argo
not keep flow as it into previous
pipelines so um
argo
using argo workflow the pipeline is
being triggered in and running in uh
data flow as well using beam programming
model
model inference is pulling model
pulling model files from gcp using moto
motor storage
and data from bigquery so
uh
after the
predictor
is executed we have predictions in form
of data in big in bigquery and then
using this data in bigquery we can
pack these predictions in whatever form
our customer needs so for some customers
we deliver it through the api and for
some customers we deliver in the form of
text files on sftp
so on this predictions in bigquery we
also built some metrics which which are
later empowering our
ui
and where analysts from our
airline can go and check and check
what's going on with any specific flight
and make some decisions if they want to
adjust uh model outputs or not and if
they want to adjust prices one follow-up
question a lot of
a lot of enterprises are looking to
future proof their platforms for scale
so can you talk about maybe how you've
designed this platform for the the scale
you expect as you onboard new customers
more models
uh yes we are pretty ambitious and we
want to
serve more airlines so of course uh
scaling and boarding new customers uh uh
is a big challenge for us but how are we
solving this we uh don't want to be a
professional services uh company we want
to we want to have one generic solution
that fits all of course it can be
configurable but it's still one solution
and then when we have every new customer
product team or our core core
engineering team don't need to do
anything
we already have uh we already have the
solution we already have all the
pipelines so we only need to hire
customer success team uh which
needs to take data from customers from
the customer transform it into our
canonical data model and then using the
pipelines that are already created start
training the model on this specific
customer data and then run this model on
our prediction pipeline
so basically they empower to do
everything by themselves and uh core
team
can focus on other features
uh
that's how we that's how we onboard new
customers is how we scale uh in the
um in the amount of the airlines we can
we can onboard but also uh
this is not the only challenge with
scaling we of course want to uh
we want to broaden our services and we
don't want don't want to only predict uh
demand for
economy carbon for instance we also want
to go farther and predict predict
premium we also want to predict uh
demand on luggage any other services you
can add to your tickets and then go to
cargo and so on so this of course will
result in uh multiple models so how we
will scale this uh
we designed the pipeline in the way that
where were we just able to add as many
models as we need and run them in
parallel so the only thing
that
we will be facing doing the challenge
will be facing is resources but of
course we can always buy them from
google
great thanks uh so we all know that ml
platforms are a fast evolving space so
curious what future enhancements you
have planned
uh yeah we we have a few uh so first of
all we want to add feature store to our
to our to our tooling so this is
something that would would would allow
us to version our feature to just better
uh manage them and then uh also
something that would let us not uh
generate them on daily basis but only
append because we don't we don't
historical uh data from the airlines it
doesn't change we only get a new portion
of data every day and for
yesterday but uh yeah we don't need to
regenerate the entire history
to be able to run new inference so this
is something we've been working on and
apart from that we also want to be able
to uh do dynamic pricing and for that we
will need to add some online model into
our inference pipeline so we will be
able to request
uh we will we will want to be able to
receive a request from customer and then
be able to uh respond immediately with
an optimal price
great yeah thank you that really
exciting road map both from a
new business capability standpoint as
well as the technology technology
capabilities of the ml platform uh so
thank you xenia for joining us today and
sharing what flyer labs does and how
you've architected an ml platform on gcp
thank you so much
yeah i really had a great conversation
um it's especially important that
everyone learn from each other as ml ops
and ml platforms are still a fairly new
field i personally learned a lot and i
know many others will as well uh
everyone if you like this content please
like and subscribe to this channel
[Music]
you